what's going on people today we've got
some interesting and pretty unexpected
news about part three of Attack on Titan
the final season which is that the first
half of part three is now confirmed to
be a one hour TV special a few weeks ago
we got a brief trailer for part three
that I spoke about on the channel and
like all of you I assumed it was going
to be broadcasters one episode a week
just like all the other previous seasons
and parts but early this morning we got
word from the official account that it's
going to be a one hour long episode
based on the crumbs of information that
I could find it seems like this first
one hour special is going to adapt
chapters 131 to 134 of the manga so all
of those four chapters should be adapted
completely from beginning to end if this
is true what it means is that when the
second special comes out later in the
year that final episode should adapt the
final five chapters making it
potentially the longest episode in the
entire series now personally when it
comes to doing it in this format of like
two super long specials I mean in terms
of quality I think that can only to be a
good thing because as we know when the
final season began it was initially 16
episodes for part one then 12 episodes
for part two so compared to that these
two one hour specials would have they
would have had a lot more focused
attention especially you know especially
the one that's coming out later in the
year because they were originally going
to release these two parts I think both
in March and they delayed part two of
part three so that's coming out later in
the year so they're giving that even
more time in this first part
um so I think in terms of quality it's
only a good thing and it's a great sign
that they're so confident in it that
they want to release it as these two
epic events rather than you know doing
the whole weekly releases thing I guess
the one potential drawback is that
because of the new format it's possible
there might not be a new anime opening
because you know sometimes in part two
when the episodes were slightly longer
than usual they just skip over the
opening to save time and so considering
that part three is now just two super
long episodes a new opening is less
likely than it would have been had they
you know just done the typical weekly
releases but that's just my speculation
it is still very possible that they do
do a new anime opening for the final two
episodes but I'm not holding my breath
I'm not sure it will happen anyhow let
me know what you think in the comments
down below do you think this is the
right way to release the final episode
or do you think they should have stuck
to the weekly releases or do you just
agree with neither of those things and
do you think they should have released
it as a long movie instead whatever you
think let me know in the comments down
below and subscribe if you want to see
my breakdown for these tv specials also
for those of you waiting part 7 of what
if Evan got the Colossal Titan is coming
along pretty well and hopefully if
everything goes to plant it will be
coming out before the end of February
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out